hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday January 25th 2016 what's
going on how are you ah you know how I'm
doing I'm not doing good Oh everybody in
Denver settling in with a big [ __ ]
smile in your face aren't you how you
[ __ ] pot smoking [ __ ] with you
goddamn hemp Poncho's congratulations to
the Broncos they deserved it right out
of the gate you know we took the ball
they stopped us and I remember when they
scored in the first Drive I was like
that was disturbingly easy and you know
they just we have they just Vaughan
[ __ ] Miller I mean if they if he was
in the backfield any quicker during the
game he'd be taking the [ __ ] snap I
mean it was brutal we just didn't have
any answers on the outlet the blood and
that's what did it not the [ __ ] field
goal and not us going for it and fourth
down I can only imagine what they're
saying on I'm doing this Sunday night I
can imagine less sports talk radio that
they're second-guessing Bill Belichick
yeah second-guess him yes second-guess
them it's just Bill Belichick oh what
are you yeah you're the other [ __ ]
you've never coached on any [ __ ]
level don't you to kick the field goal
I love all people think like like
something earlier in the game if they
just did this that that that doesn't
change everything after that I mean how
many [ __ ] back to the futures do they
have to make that you see if you change
one thing that it changes everything
else so if the Patriots did kick the
[ __ ] thing and we got to within five
and when we got the ball back the fact
that a touchdown would put us ahead
rather than us being down by eight they
would have had a completely different
[ __ ] defense okay before they [ __ ]
do all of that second-guessing [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] virzi was going through
that I said I was saying I was saying
when they did it was dumb oh did you
non coach virzi am gonna listen to you
as opposed to [ __ ] Belichick when
they did it I was like I love that I
love the call going for it we weren't
able to move the [ __ ] ball at all on
offense the entire [ __ ] game we will
the only reason why we had a touchdown
was because they had that [ __ ]
lateral and even then then we missed a
[ __ ] extra point it just it wasn't
our day even when we had got a gift we
[ __ ] it up and then we gave it right
back with the pic and then they scored
but yeah we weren't able to move the
[ __ ] ball every time Brady went back
there was somebody in his face you know
chomping at the [ __ ] is his legs as
he was trying to throw the [ __ ] thing
you're that close I I agreed with going
for it it didn't work out but you know
that's how life is sometimes so but it
was a great season and for what they
accomplished with all the injuries and
all that type of [ __ ] it was amazing and
I got to tell you I am I'm definitely
rooting for Peyton Manning I'd like to
see him go out like John Elway it'd be
pretty cool for another guy and the
Broncos does that but then he also you
got to love Cam Newton you know Jesus
Christ don't think I don't like about
Cam Newton is one more person tells me
there's nobody having more fun than him
[Music]
it's like I get it he's having fun
he's also totally [ __ ] hamming it up
and making sure his next sneaker deal
would be it will be even ten times what
the [ __ ] he has right now let's not just
let's not be totally naive here and just
act like everything he's doing it's just
because he loves playing the game he
wasn't this [ __ ] animated when he was
at [ __ ] Auburn I used to watch those
games root against the word against him
so I would watch that I was he wasn't
doing all that [ __ ] but then again he
couldn't get paid or at least legally he
couldn't get paid back then so you know
what was the point I danced it every
time he [ __ ] did I love when that one
guy [ __ ] they threw the screen pass
and he ran all the way to the other side
of the field by the time he gets there
Cam Newton
runs in with them and kind of [ __ ] it
jumps in on that guy super bowl super
his touchdown celibate celebration and
then the cameraman is just following Cam
Newton for the rest of the time and in
my in my business that's that's called
not just not stealing a scene it's
called Jesus Christ I don't do enough
acting - even though steel machine is
when you're better than the other person
upstaging somebody he was upstaging him
so I just don't need anybody else
telling me how much fun Cam Newton is
having I get it he's having a good time
but he's also completely hamming it up
because when he does he makes a zillion
dollars however it's crushing as the
Patriots loss was like I literally had
to I had to go for a walk after they
lost and I got to tell you I felt like
we were gonna lose that game you know
sometime in the second quarter I was
just like this I can feel it this just
isn't our day it just wasn't Brady never
let me they were all over him he never
got comfortable and he wasn't screaming
and yelling and getting people going I
thought but our [ __ ] defense played
great but I don't know I just sometimes
you can just feel it's just not you
[ __ ] day so I literally had to go for
a walk what to the bank I mailed
something I got the car washed it was
like nobody there was like a ghost town
it was just like you know some [ __ ]
nerds or whatever who don't give a [ __ ]
about sports and some poor bastards who
had to work and yeah I went to the car
wash and then I went to this
Mediterranean Middle East and one of the
[ __ ] it is got one of those wraps the
shwarma wraps whatever the [ __ ] you call
it and it actually worked out perfect I
walked a few blocks over I got the rap I
ate it I watched some of the Carolina
Arizona game and then when I came back
right as I came back the guy was
finished in my car and he put his hand
up like whose car is this was [ __ ]
perfect perfect timing it was about the
only good thing that happened during
those three hours of watching the
[ __ ] game but anyways I got to tell
you is bad
as as bad as the the feeling I had when
the Patriots lost the one thing that
cheered me up was watching that Carolina
fans fall out of the [ __ ] stands that
was one of the funniest [ __ ] things
I've seen in a long time he just
completely he missed timed when the
player was coming down I think he I
think he just ran down and he just
missed misjudged where the rail was and
he just slammed into it and just went
right up and over straight up and over I
mean if you if you put a coat rack on
wheels it would have landed lighter than
this guy did there was just not nothing
athletic about it it was just all
[ __ ] it was it inertia at the proper
physics term he just read that I just
wish I could have heard his thoughts
when he was at the tipping point when
his legs were right up were pointing at
the 12 and his head was at 6 o'clock
right as it started to come around to
about 11:45 you know he was lying to
himself hanging onto the rail like I got
this I got this ah [ __ ] oh this stupid
dad jeans just shooting up in the air
right from the gap and just [ __ ]
lands on the ground I liked when he got
up too and then he tried to like climb
back up on the stands and that dude was
there like I know buddy why don't you
just walk around we don't need you
fallin down again I'll tell you what the
funny thing is you know there's gonna be
some lawyer scaring the [ __ ] out of the
owner of that team that emotionless
maniac that they kept cutting to when he
would just be sitting there like he was
listening to the verdict of his own
murder trial the [ __ ] is with that guy
is he just focused on the Superbowl
everybody in his luxury box is going
nuts he's got his [ __ ] furred up wife
that's when you know you got money when
your wife has a fur coat and hasn't been
spray-painted you know that's when you
know that it's it that you guys are
living a level of wealth that you don't
even run into commoners do you you know
there's always some [ __ ] that's got to
come along and [ __ ] spray-paint
somebody's fur coat which I've never
understood it's like the animal died and
now he's gonna throw out a tide at least
it was a jacket
you know what I mean like if somebody
came on killed me and made a jacket out
of me I wouldn't want you to spray-paint
it you know they're just gonna throw it
out and then I'm just like a [ __ ]
jacket you know in the landfill right
floating in the ocean let the [ __ ] walk
around with it anyways jesus [ __ ]
christ
I'll tell you right now nobody's having
more fun in the National Football League
oh god I was watching the game with a
buddy of mine we were just throwing out
the cliches okay he gets he gets it he's
the first one here and he's the last one
to leave I'll tell you right now you can
be twenty two guys like that I could
coach the Super Bowl I'll tell you right
now you have to know where you are on
the field why would you run a five yard
route when you need six yards for a
first down I mean that just doesn't make
any sense I'll tell you out there
they're just having fun out there
they're just having fun that's what this
games all about they're out there
they're loose he's just out there
slinging it anyways and just like that
my [ __ ] football season is over so
who do you like in the Super Bowl I'll
tell you what I don't like have you seen
that [ __ ] advertisement for Super
Bowl 50 the 50s and gold and for
whatever reason there's this woman
standing there looking like the hot
chick that walks in in some gumshoe
movie from the [ __ ] 1940s she's
standing there on a raincoat and high
heels with like a golden umbrella
telling you it's it's over it's [ __ ]
over the bills hired a I don't know what
they are they had a woman for some job
oh but it's [ __ ] over it's done it's
done those three hours well you could
get away as a married guy you could just
get away for three hours it's it's over
it's guy I it's gonna sound like the
Westminster Dog Show
in about seven years you know we had a
great run we had a great run and now
it's over
you know but it's our own damn fault
it's our own damn fault so you know what
it was we just couldn't hide the joy we
were having watching football without
him we couldn't hide the joy and there's
nothing that annoys a [ __ ] woman like
a bunch of guys going and having a good
time without him so they're in that
dressing in pink for a [ __ ] month
it's it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] over I
wish I just knew I just knew I wish I
knew that it was going to come to this I
would have tried to enjoy you know my
first 37 38 years of football what they
just flew by I would have tried to enjoy
him a little bit more and now it's over
we should make a train which is what we
should do we should just trade him the
WNBA just go like what if we just give
you a league that we started it'll be
almost like a divorce will you just get
it even though you didn't do anything or
maybe you'd like emotionally supported
the guy or some [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
you say at the court right you just give
them the WNBA you can be the
commissioners all the owners the
commentators the refs you could be
everybody in the stands we'll give you
your section of Buffalo Wild Wings you
know just just don't take NFL football
from us candy candy just not just can
you give us can just leave us with that
can we just have that oh god maybe I'm
just too old to understand it coach can
you tell us what happened there in the
first half I just don't know if I'm
ready for that you know I don't know I
just get it I don't what do you go now I
guess I guess the only place left is you
you become one of those weird old guys
that plays chess in the park
you know it is about chess it's boring
and quiet enough that they don't notice
that you're over there without him
enjoying yourself
you know that's the genius you ever see
a guy who's been married for like 50
years like the genius of him I swear to
God
the genius of them is they [ __ ] they
know how to have a good time without
their wife noticing so it doesn't pique
her interest right she's [ __ ] over in
the corner she doesn't give a [ __ ] right
but young guys were idiots we come home
with a big grin on her face talking
about how awesome it was blah blah and
all they hear is this [ __ ] had
the nerve to go out for three hours and
not miss me and not think about me well
we'll see about that won't we [ __ ]
over it's over just like the Patriots
season so who do you guys like in the
who do you guys like in the I'm trying
to think of an activity that women do
[ __ ] group that they have that I
would like to infiltrate and I for the
life of me I can't think of it you know
well they got the 4-h club girl scouting
any those feminist groups there'd be a
funny thing to join join one of those
[ __ ] groups and act like you're a
feminist you just go down there and you
say like the most ignorant but like yet
it's still pro women [ __ ] come down
there with a [ __ ] bud tall yeah I
just wanted to say you know I came down
here to support you broads
you know I think it's I think it's
[ __ ] up the way the guy treats you you
know just because you run around with
the skirt and it takes you longer to get
ready doesn't mean you can't run the
company right my right ladies bill we
really appreciate you coming down here
we think what you're saying is positive
which is just some buzz words here that
we put into a spreadsheet a little
pamphlet thing that we'd like you to
look at
maybe could not say them the next
meeting maybe take a couple of weeks off
showing up every week wait for him to
kick me out then I sue them for being
sexist um I'm just a grumpy old man
that's all it is
I'm a grumpy old man who wants things to
stay the same you know do I make any
money off the NFL I don't I do have the
mute button you got it you gotta love
the mute button anytime they cut to the
chick on the sidelines I just [ __ ] it I
hit mute you know just trying to keep it
going
you know just for another couple more
weeks how come we can't blah blah blah
okay alright Jesus Christ I think it
really comes up what are you gonna do
it's it you know it's [ __ ] over it's
our own goddamn fault
we just had too much [ __ ] fun without
him so you know the next thing we start
just you come home you tone it down
[ __ ] tone it down anyways let's plow
ahead here so I still haven't even said
what is it the Super Bowl who are you
like Panthers have Broncos you know I
was impressed that the Panthers [ __ ]
we're kicking the [ __ ] out of Arizona
and they didn't take their foot off the
gas pedal this week I don't know but the
Broncos have that [ __ ] defense but
our offensive line steaks doesn't stink
we're just banged up so I don't know I
don't know how good they thought I don't
know I know you know what I don't even
[ __ ] know I'm still so [ __ ]
annoyed by that goddamn the finality of
not even that we lost cuz I felt Denver
was the better [ __ ] team
god damn [ __ ] all right that's
it plowing ahead oh by the way did I
mention I saw the hateful eight didn't
anybody see that
did anybody I came up I talked about it
I saw it in 70 millimeter at the
ArcLight here and in Los Angeles had an
intermission
they had an overture in the beginning
there were no coming attractions because
who the [ __ ] gonna shoot that the
70-millimeter right and I absolutely
[ __ ] love that movie
from start to finish I love the pacing
of it I love the ho I just loved I loved
it
I just think the whole fight was just an
experience like Tarantino's I gotta give
a [ __ ] about your cell phone how your
[ __ ] brain is all scrambled now cuz
you're looking at an iPad screen all
goddamn day long I don't give a [ __ ] the
movies this long this is the movie I
wanted to make and you can settle the
[ __ ] or leave those it's just an
experience I absolutely [ __ ] love
that movie
oh speaking of with speaking of iPad so
you see when the Patriots iPads won oh
that was strange huh do the Broncos go
out been that weird that's just one of
those strange things just one of those
fluke thinks that happened it happened
and I it's all good it's all good
because it happened to the Patriots now
had it happened the other way around and
it was in our Stadium oh Jesus how many
months would ESPN talk about that you
know verse he called me today instead of
former quarterback I think it was for
the Giants I don't even know who was
saying like yeah we'd take air out of
the ball all the [ __ ] time everybody
did it and everybody does it once again
and I know you guys are like on Jesus
bill how long you gonna harp on this
well they talked about it for [ __ ]
eight months you know I think since you
know the judge threw it out of court I
mean it hasn't been eight months since
then has it September October November
December January
you got another three months of this
[ __ ]
anyways enough of that [ __ ] I uh oh by
the way I started that that that series
top boy t.o.p boy on netflix and [ __ ]
great show two episodes in enjoying it
but Jesus Christ you got to put on the
[ __ ] subtitles good lord
mumble in fast as [ __ ] it's almost as
bad as peaky blinders but peaky blinders
you can understand this [ __ ] was
supposed to happen like a hundred years
ago this [ __ ] here as far as I can tell
supposed to be going on right now and I
still can't understand I don't think
they say in it
enough stamps calm everybody here we got
a little advertising for this week
stamps calm you know there's got to be a
better way to mail and ship stuff going
to the post office takes up so much time
leasing a postage meter is way too
expensive turns out there is a better
way
stamps.com stamps calm you can buy and
print official US postage for anyone or
package right from your desks using your
own computer and even get special
postage discounts you can't find at the
post office plus stamps calm is more
powerful than a postage at just a
fraction of the cost you can save at
least fifty percent compared to a
postage meter and you avoid all the time
consuming trips to the post office I use
stamps comm anytime I send my posters
out right now you can sign up for stamps
calm and use my last name BER for this
special offer four week trial plus $110
bonus offer including postage and a
digital stay on scale don't wait go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in birth that
stamps com enter BIR alright MV MT
watches movement watches was started by
two college dropouts man with the idea
to make quality watches that don't break
your bank starting at just 95 bucks and
sold online they cut out all the
[ __ ] retail markup they sent me some
watches these things are [ __ ] alright
quality materials and sleek designs
their pert the perfect everyday watch
it's you know if you get mugged you
don't give a [ __ ] right here you go take
the goddamn thing go buy another one
before you get at home easy it's easy
order online today for free shipping
free returns in a 24 month warranty join
the movement and say no to big brand
retail markups and saying yes to great
style check out MVM t watches dot-com /
Berg and you'll get 15% off your entire
purchase that's MVM t watches dot-com /
/ and lastly but not leastly
blue apron and everybody all right
listen you don't need to know how to
cook but you need to know how to cook it
right if you want to start nailing the
top [ __ ] chicks out there right I'm
kidding all right now
it helps anything else especially look
like me you know it's helpful you can
whip up a dish you know grab a couple of
wine glasses act like you know what
you're doing you know but you'll go I
don't go to the [ __ ] supermarket well
that's what blue apron comes in all
right not only do you get to feel like
you know your way around the kitchen but
cooking at home means eating healthier
and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout again but where do you
start blue apron has you covered for
less than $10 per meal blue apron
delivers all the fresh ingredients you
need to create home-cooked meals just
follow the easy step-by-step
instructions each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less no overwhelming
trips to the grocery store no more sad
takeout no matter your dietary
preferences blue apron makes it a breeze
to discover and prepare dishes like
chicken and sage biscuit potpie shrimp
and pineapple fried rice Philly style
hoagie with green peppers onions
mushrooms and aged cheddar sauce chicken
scaparelli nee whatever the [ __ ] this is
with Rob we get it lemon butter shrimp
what am I gonna read the whole menu all
right I got it there's a bunch of [ __ ]
on it a tomato quiche with a simple
green salad right in your own kitchen
not in the bathroom you make it in the
kitchen and recipes between 500 700
calories proportioned delicious and good
for you right now you can get your first
two meals for free at blue apron com / /
that's blue apron com / / blue apron a
better way to cook all right here we go
you know be cool though if there was
like a female like Vince Lombardi who
came in you know what I mean and she had
the exact same like like demeanor the
study will have their classic sakes why
don't anybody grab a towel cover your
dicks West
let's focus on next week oh by the way
uh I want to thank Brian tissue from
letting me be a part of the Bonzo bash
this past Friday night I got to go down
there and co-host it with him and just
the amount of drummers that I saw that
night and I got to stand behind him
there's any YouTube video you're gonna
see my dumb [ __ ] head just staring at
their base drum foot these are some of
the guys that played last Friday night
Stephen Perkins Jane's Addiction Chad
Smith from the Chili Peppers Dave
Lombardo from dead cross and Slayer who
else him going from memory oh there's a
got a Greg Potter from the Buddy Rich
band guy plays in the Buddy Rich band
and crushed a Zeppelin song that's
pretty much running the gamut Simon
right
last time I saw Simon Wright play I saw
him on the who made who tour rob a few
so from Skid Row last time I saw him
they opened for Aerosmith New Year's Eve
1989 December 31st at the boss then get
will Calhoun was there Brad Whitford
from Aerosmith Carmen apathy oh my god
it uh ray lazier from corn absolutely
destroyed Achilles last fan he's got
John Hummel I never heard of [ __ ]
destroy cashmere just so many [ __ ]
amazing drummers and I actually got to
sit in which is [ __ ] hilarious I got
to sit in between guys at that level I
played that song off of the presents
album for you love and I'm sorry for you
love for your life and I want to thank
everyone in the Moby Dick's for help and
walk me through that song you know you
know what it was I [ __ ] up a lot
during the song but I nailed the
arrangement as far as like all the
changes I was on it for that and I find
that if you do that that people in the
crowd don't notice that you [ __ ] up
the Phills there was like one big fill
and I [ __ ] rimmed out on the thing I
was so [ __ ] pissed what are you gonna
do but it was uh it was just a [ __ ]
amazing night
four hours [ __ ] long watching these
guys and they had this Bonham [ __ ]
Vista light set the exact same style kit
that he had if you watch the Sun and the
song remains the same and this the
[ __ ] kick drum was wide open they had
nothing in there they didn't have a felt
strip going across it it was one of the
sickest sounds I've ever heard in my
life big 26 inch kit they had the two
timpani x' to the left the hi-hat and
then the [ __ ] gong and it's I'm so
pissed at the end of the song I didn't
hit the [ __ ] dog how many [ __ ]
opportunities to get to do that and I
blew it
but I just I just had the best time
doing it and then of course I'm driving
home it was down in Anaheim and I'm
driving home and the best thing about
driving home at night in LA is there's
finally no traffic and a [ __ ] cruisin
and all of a sudden the [ __ ] five
just comes to a grinding halt in three
four lanes merge down to one and then
are forced off of the highway into like
a neighborhood because the only time
they obviously that they can fix the
highways is at night so I have empathy
for these state workers out here but
sucked for me and I had like a [ __ ]
meltdown for about five minutes and I
was texting everyone that I got a number
from that was on the show telling them
not to get on the five and [ __ ]
bruton and once again I just understand
why people buy fast cars out here unless
you have a pickup truck with a trailer
and you can drive that car you can tow
the car to a race track I just don't
understand you know these [ __ ] cars
you see out here that can go like 180
160 20 miles an hour some of these
[ __ ] cars it's like where are you
doing that I don't know it's [ __ ]
ridiculous i beeped at this lady today I
was probably a dick I just really I
can't [ __ ] stand people when they sit
at a goddamn red light you're right
behind him and then when the light turns
green they put on their [ __ ] left
turn signal and then you beep out and
they're like what the [ __ ] it's like
give me a heads up give me a heads up so
I could have backed off and gone around
you you [ __ ] dick now that
people behind me I gotta go by him I
miss the [ __ ] light now I'm on your
schedule you know like that that's never
happened to you you've never been the
person behind that person you don't
[ __ ] remember now you're first in
line you just say [ __ ] it sorry most of
this [ __ ] everything that I'm saying
women in the NFL all of this [ __ ] most
of this [ __ ] has nothing to do with it
has to do with the fact that my team
lost you know so now I'm just [ __ ]
grumpy anyways for the Gipper
alright oh hey I'm gonna be playing out
live again if you guys into it stand up
Oh Dean Del Ray Dean Del Rey's 50th
birthday you got to come down to this at
the El Rey Theatre del Rey at the El Rey
it's going to be an unbelievable [ __ ]
lineup of comedians and musicians to
celebrate Dean Del Rey's 50th birthday
and of course my [ __ ] internet cuts
out I finally had the [ __ ] thing
finally had it I had it all [ __ ]
lined up I was ready to read off the
whole thing and what happens it just
[ __ ] disappears you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright well this is what I know Joe
Rogan's gonna be doing some stand-up
there I will be on it Chris D'Elia let
me get to the flyer here let me get to
the flyer there it is there's the flyer
alright Brian Redman Joe bartnik Rose
both tailgate legend Joe part Nick Dean
del Rey is going to be there and after
we do a bunch of stand-up we're going to
do some from what I heard there's going
to be all these musicians there and
they're gonna play the entire highway to
hell album Rudy Sarzo is going to be
there from Ozzy Osbourne Dave Kushner
from Velvet Revolver add the gout does
the music for f is for
family Dave Lombardo Tracy Gunz Gilby
clack from Guns N'Roses it's gonna be
[ __ ] say it's gonna be it's gonna be a
lot of fun so come on down February 2nd
you can get tickets at golden voice calm
all right let's uh let's continue on
here with with the with the podcast what
else did I want to talk about is there
anything anything at all is i if I as I
settle into the fact that my [ __ ]
football season is over
oh Jesus Christ a Patrice O'Neal benefit
how the [ __ ] that I almost forget that
late great Patrice O'Neal the I think
this is the fourth one we've done yeah
13 14 15 16 yeah this is the fourth one
it's already flying by it sold out there
will be a few tickets released at the
right before the show starts there's
always a few people that requested
tickets and then they don't show up so
there's a chance if you walk up there
might be some tickets it's gonna be an
amazing line-up and as always other than
the money that we use to pay to rent out
the theater all monies goes to Patrice
is loved ones and it's really made an
unbelievably positive effect on their
lives you know his mom has been able to
get a condo and his stepdaughters going
to private school since the benefit and
just the quality of their lives
basically stayed the same you know
Patrice was taking care of them so it's
really it's the greatest thing that I'm
involved in during the course of the
year and I'm so happy that you guys step
it up every year and buy tickets so I
want to thank everybody who bought
tickets means the world to me and
everybody involved and all the comics
that take time out of their schedule to
come down there and and perform and it's
just a it's just an awesome thing and
we're just gonna keep doing it as long
as you guys keep showing up alright so
thank you thank you for that and with
that let's get into some of the reads
here for for this week all right
what do we have to hear 33 minutes all
right all right hackie hate hey Bill how
uh uh he says I am NOT a Patriots fan I
am a die-hard Bears fan
after the Patriots lost all I saw on
Facebook was people trashing Brady and
bringing up Trump and deflate gate I get
it
they're on most they're on top most of
the time and people love to trash him or
whoever is winning at life now let's
stop giving excuses to these pansy-ass
[ __ ] sports fan who's spent sports
fans who spend 90% of their [ __ ] time
talking about gossip it all gets
classified under gossip every hack who
was who was a static that the pastry's
loss is an [ __ ] especially the ones
who will declare they could care less
about sports Congrats you're about as
cool as the guy who paints his face the
only time I talk [ __ ] about the Patriots
is to remind them of 1985 even that's
pretty weak go bears
yeah but you know if you're on top you
gotta expect that people are gonna give
you [ __ ] the only thing I didn't like
was was when the Broncos defense you
know though we're getting sugar here
what about Tom Brady it's like well then
win a [ __ ] Super Bowl win four of
them and they'll talk about you the
Patriots never talk [ __ ] about the
Broncos they never said that they were
better than the Broncos and I also love
too it's just like you know they were
favorites during one fit like the
Patriots made themselves favorites that
you know it's really overrated is is
being a favorite or being an underdog
has nothing to do with your team it has
to do with the [ __ ] dope in the
Buffalo Wild Wings who's betting on
games all right what Vegas tries to do
is they try to get money on both sides
of the ball so they try to pick a number
all right that's going to entice people
to go 5050 that's why the line changes
during the course of the week did one
team get better another team get worse I
mean if there's an injury yes but
generally speaking no what happens is is
this too much money going to one side so
they need to entice people to come back
the other side because if you know that
you
like 90% of the money on one side of the
ball that could completely [ __ ] over the
gambling ring or the they don't like
those odds
and because ties lose that's enough to
tip it in their [ __ ] favor that's
basically what goes on which is why you
know if you look back in oh seven when
the Patriots beat the Giants the last
game of the year and the Giants put up
like [ __ ] 33 or 34 points and we only
won by like three or something that's
why like a month later we were still
14-point favorites
it had no the Patriots are overhyped
they weren't overhyped what happened was
the Super Bowl brings out people who
don't know [ __ ] about football all right
it brings out the [ __ ] ladies it
brings out all you know there's nothing
worse than a Super Bowl party if you
give a [ __ ] about football if you really
like the Super but if really like
football through really football fan you
watch it alone or you watch it with like
two or three other people that keep
their [ __ ] mouth shut all right but
what happens is during the Super Bowl
that brings out all the [ __ ] the
novice fans that people don't even watch
and all they see is a teen and oh the
[ __ ] bar they know Brady like they
know they know Tom Brady the way I know
Darth Vader all right I can't tell you a
[ __ ] thing about the last like I
don't know how many there's been since
the original three I know Vader
is [ __ ] Luke's father and that
[ __ ] Luke and Leia a brother and
sister and that they kind of had like
this sexual tension and wanted to [ __ ]
each other in the beginning which i
think is a really weird thing to put
into a kid's movie don't you maybe he
didn't know that when he initially wrote
it and then he just needed a good left
turn when he was right in the second one
I have no [ __ ] idea but I think the
way he tried to make it up was with
those gerbils in the third one you know
knowing where the [ __ ] they did you know
I know what the [ __ ] they did so anyway
so that's as much as I as much as I know
about Star Wars these people know about
footballs so then they come in they go
to Vegas and everybody goes in and
thinks that they're [ __ ] Sean Connery
and James Bond right they with you know
they [ __ ] go down there and they got
some
Vegas sued on their wife's wearing some
[ __ ] you know sparkly number and
everybody's out there you know stepping
outside of themselves and say I want to
gamble I want to get in the action who's
playing I don't know who that other team
is I know Tom Brady is let me we put 100
bucks on his stone the CLEF of his
[ __ ] chin and that's how the line
goes from what it should be about three
four points - all the way up to 14
that's what the [ __ ] happens all right
then that was for everybody who doesn't
[ __ ] gamble okay
all right bill enough already we get it
your team lost and you [ __ ] you're in
a country mood thank God that guy fell
out of stance he didn't even look that
drunk I just loved his [ __ ] Gap jeans
just [ __ ] straight up in the air all
right next question here oh by the way
if you'd like to donate to this podcast
all you got to do is just go to next
time you go to Amazon if you're next I'm
gonna buy something on that just go to
my website billboard.com click on the
podcast page and then you just click on
the amazon link it just takes you there
it doesn't cost you any extra money you
might you know later on in life if your
index finger wears out you might think
like you know what if I didn't do those
extra two clicks with my index finger
maybe I would have had another 10
minutes of joy and no [ __ ] constant
pain and my index finger other than that
there's really nothing I even do it I
even go when I go to Amazon well why
wouldn't I guess I get the money right
you know I did I went on there and I
fixed my [ __ ] cool I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened am i cooler this year
at the Rose Bowl
it's been to every Rose Bowl that I've
been to and I've been to eight of them
at this point and I never had a [ __ ]
problem and at some point like my cooler
basically it opens up to a point
you know the hinges stop it from opening
and then there's a strap to keep it from
going any further and I don't know what
happened because I [ __ ] passed out
like at like 10 o'clock in the morning
so and I'd even noticed that my cooler
was [ __ ] up but at the end of the
night when I got my cooler back the it
had basically been decapitated the strap
was busted and the hinges were busted
and I was like what the [ __ ] what
happened you know it's like the Hulk
opened the thing up or something just
like just open it a little it's fine
then I was thinking when I fell down
once I was drunk that I land on the
cooler and it's like no I wouldn't
noticed that I landed flat on my pie
landed like that [ __ ] guy what he
fell out of the stand that's how I fell
I fell on the grass do you realize I was
on a fairway a strait fairway golf
course and I lost my balance and fell
down that's how [ __ ] drunk I was and
you know what it was [ __ ] great so
anyways I went to I wish I didn't go to
Amazon I just looked up Igloo cooler
repair kit and they got like there's two
different kinds of hinges and I
accidentally ordered two of them and I
only need one of them so I have an extra
repair kit and I know you know the odds
and they send you like three sets a
hinges you know if you have like the the
giant one you know the person who kills
his wife and doesn't want anybody to
know and just says she's on vacation and
he cuts her up like they have that size
hinge for that cooler and then they just
got you know the happy drunk that falls
down on New Year's Day
you know so they come with three sets of
hinges for each so I have an entire
extra one so anybody out there who has
like a cooler that needs to be replaced
that comes with everything even like the
drain little drain hole [ __ ] spout
thing it's got that the strap does come
separately I don't have an extra strap
but I have an extra repair kit so if
anybody wants it send us an email with
an address and I'll send it out to you
because what else am I gonna do with it
I'm not going to throw it out and
someday if I ever move you know I got to
pack up something that I don't even
[ __ ] need so there you go
oh by the way I'm still in the running
here to maybe get this drum room made
slash podcast room in the back of my
garage as always this major major
[ __ ] structural issues but I don't
just got I got a I got a show up that
part of the house but there's there's
all these these all these [ __ ] issues
that I can't even talk about because
you know I'm getting a permit I'm doing
all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] I know somebody
like well you don't need to focus if
you're building within the structure if
you're not adding any square footage I
know all that [ __ ] but like eyes you
know any time you start hammering in
your [ __ ] garage your neighbors hear
it they [ __ ] rat you out I just don't
need the [ __ ] headache so I'm doing
my due diligence and it's taking a long
time but I'm gonna I'm gonna make this
I'm gonna make this [ __ ] happen and I
have a 71 Ludwig green Sparkle all
bottom size drums and I'm gonna make
sure that they [ __ ] fit in there and
I'm gonna [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
what do I care right
you know the oceans are all fished out
the government takes all your [ __ ]
money
you know I don't give a [ __ ] I'm going
all out with this thing this thing I'm
literally gonna be able to pull I'm
gonna tell this guy if I'm able to do
this and I'm not gonna have a [ __ ]
problem legally and I can build the
[ __ ] thing I want to build I'm
literally gonna be able to play at 2
o'clock in the [ __ ] morning and no
one's even gonna hear they might in
meit's not like a stereos on really low
but I'd never be a douche enough to play
then at least sober that'll be great
then right anytime I'm bugging my wife I
can just walk out the back door go into
my garage sit down and put on a Zeppelin
album Guns and Roses [ __ ] all my
[ __ ] [ __ ] I listen to when I was
growing up Queens of the Stone Age you
know I want the point what else do you
[ __ ] eat you know what else I need I
need a bar out there right flat-screen
TV you know it's funny about a man cave
when somebody really goes throws down in
their [ __ ] mancave all I hear is I am
NOT happily married and what you're
doing is you're building a mini version
of what your life would look like if you
weren't that what your house would look
like if you weren't married like after
you show them the house with all the
throw pillows and all the [ __ ]
potpourri and all that [ __ ] you bring
your buddy out to the garage and just
like yeah if I wasn't married like this
is what it would look like
[Music]
but you know it's funny about that I'm
old enough to know that if your house
did look like that the lice I see the
loneliness in it because the bottom line
is a man cave what it is is like what
you're building is what you wish you had
you wish you could afford when you were
[ __ ] 22 years old that's basically it
and the problem is is if you do it
honestly if you're actually work your
balls off you know and you don't steal
from anybody earning that [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's gonna take you to you're about 50
unless you're one of these [ __ ] nerds
in Silicon Valley that comes up with an
app or some [ __ ] you know you really
don't get paid until you get close to 50
that's just how it is you know it's just
how it is
except for Cam Newton he's getting paid
around if you look up fun in the
dictionary
anyways I yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] make a
little podcast thing I mean I don't have
a lot of room but I'm gonna I'm gonna
[ __ ] do it up right
and you know getting back and taking
lessons again to the [ __ ] that I'm
actually paying attention to now that I
never paid attention to how I hold on to
the sticks where I'm hitting the snare
drum my balance all of that [ __ ] it used
to be all about going on YouTube seeing
some guy do one of those gospel chop
[ __ ] licks and I'm gonna go down here
and [ __ ] just do this for [ __ ] nine
days in a row and then I'll be able to
do that you know pull this Phil off next
time I walk into Guitar Center and and
then meanwhile all my other playing
sucked and I've just had this total
epiphany about all of it and it's funny
I'm not doing nearly as much as I used
to do but I think I'm playing better
than I ever played and I don't know it's
[ __ ] exciting gives me a reason to
get up in the morning you know so
anyways let's move on to the next
question here oh my god did I tell you
guys how I butchered that [ __ ] pork
chop meal that I made uh still sick over
that
like I'm eating pork chops again this
week cause I have to redeem myself all
right so the hacky hate thing yeah that
just kind of comes with winning games or
whatever all right no Asian diversity at
the Oscars bill hello from Canada would
love to hear what your take is on why no
one is complaining about the lack of the
agents at the Oscars oh you [ __ ]
that's the bit I was going to do that
was the bit I was gonna do yeah that's
it says he goes as an agent I don't care
because a I suspect we aren't producing
good enough [ __ ] not to not know it
we're not producing good enough [ __ ]
not because we're Asian being agents
aren't getting sweet rolls because I'm
not profitable they aren't going to cast
an Asian parentheses or black a female
actor that would make more money out of
some white conspiracy dude you had like
[ __ ] two sets of parentheses in there
agents aren't getting sweet rolls
because it's not profitable they aren't
going there they aren't going to not
cast an Asian or black a female actor
that well I see what you saying they're
not they aren't going to not cast an
Asian actor that would make more money
out of some white conspiracy so you're
saying if they if they would make them
money then they would see who cares if
you don't like how the Oscars to find
the best whatever I don't get why and
then that's the end of it I see what
you're saying well yeah you're looking
at it from a very like money like I
think that's a lot of times sometimes
you know it looks like it's racism a lot
of times it's just money but what I
think American cinema is finally
realizing is that there's a whole bunch
of other people in the world that they
can actually get money from if they gave
a [ __ ] to make a movie that would appeal
to them and the only thing reason why I
think they're doing that is because
everybody stole movies and it's so hard
to make money off of them now and
there's such a big [ __ ] risk because
what happened to the music business
has happened / is happening to the movie
business right now which is why there's
really no more like from like 20 million
dollars to like 70 million dollars they
don't make movies in that budget anymore
they just don't it's either like some
[ __ ] 100 million dollar Star Wars
action hero movie or it's like [ __ ]
below ten million dollars it seems all
the way down to like a hundred grand
like indie sort of you know micro budget
[ __ ] thing so yeah I see what you're
saying yeah I mean yeah there's no
agents there either where's the outcry
for that well people don't people give a
[ __ ] about themselves that's the one
thing that I can say about people in
general straight across the board you
know which is why I guess white people
need because they're running [ __ ] quote
running [ __ ] you know what I mean like
they're all cooperating with one another
because there's white people in those
positions they need to take the time to
actually give a [ __ ] about other stuff
because I got to be honest with you I
thought that kid that played eazy-e and
straight out of Compton he should have
gotten nominated he was he was the
[ __ ] [ __ ] in that movie I should know
that actor's name he was you know what
god damn it why don't I step outside my
whiteness I'm gonna I'm gonna set the
example here right now and I'll tell you
right now there's nobody having more fun
right now going on the internet than
this guy you look up fun on the internet
there'll be a picture of me eazy-e actor
Eric Lynn Wright is here Jason Mitchell
on playing eazy-e that [ __ ] guy was
he should have got some that he even get
a Golden Globe did he get nominated for
that that was one of those movies that I
actually didn't even want to see there
was some line that what's-his-face
Giamatti said you know me okay I don't
like that that's 40 yelled whatever the
[ __ ] yells I got Jesus Christ this this
looks really heavy-handed you know what
I mean and then they always have to have
the you know they always have to have
the white white angel in those movies
when they show racism so then white
people will go so they can lie to
themselves and be like yeah if I was
there that's the white guy I would be
I'd be the angel white guy I wouldn't be
the the you know the racist guy yeah I
know it's a very it's a very interesting
the whole [ __ ] thing is is really
interesting I don't know I have no idea
I mean I think you shouldn't just say
look black actors should be nominated
you should [ __ ] then back it up you
know what I mean and give shoutouts to
people that [ __ ] deserve you so be
like Jason Mitchell plain easy straight
out of Compton who the [ __ ] is gonna say
[ __ ] I got something or maybe they did
do that I gotta be honest with you I
don't I don't really pay attention to
award shows I [ __ ] can't stand up
there horrific they're [ __ ] horrific
they're boring as hell there's usually
one moment that's worth [ __ ] watching
and at that it with the internet you're
not gonna miss it they're just gonna
show it to you so why would you waste
four hours of your life watching the
[ __ ] like for the Golden Globes the the
the moment of the night was Jim Carrey
Jim Carrey stole that he met [ __ ]
speech was hilarious and from what I've
heard from people out here he just wing
that thing that's how [ __ ] funny that
guy is and watching him do that in the
brutal honesty of it really made me wish
I could still watch him to stand up to
be honest with you all right here we go
to your health good sir bill I've heard
you
discuss many topics with with yourself
on the podcast about health and
longevity of the major topics ie food
and exercise I would have to suggest
considering another area to focus on
breathing now Jesus I got to work on
this - breathing is huge how you breathe
and the types of breaths you take during
the day to really change your body for
the better I just literally thought
about breathing and got more relaxed
this is this yoga [ __ ] that I try to
slow my brain down for conscious
breathing conscious breathing are you
gonna plug your book in the middle of
this you [ __ ] you know what you
got me he suckered me and but I'm gonna
read it like deep thoughts by Jack
Handey here we go conscious breathing is
a book and a great place to start also a
man by the name of wim HOF is doing
amazing things and has been on Joe
Rogan's podcast you may not have three
hours to listen to it but if you run
into Joe I'm sure he can give you the
breakdown
thanks for the free laughs no I'll
listen to anybody that's on Rogen's
podcast Joe Rogan's podcast the fastest
[ __ ] three hours you're ever gonna
spay you very ever lucky enough to be a
[ __ ] guest you can be like aunt
Minnie like 40 minutes and then all of a
sudden you're like so how the [ __ ] is it
like seven o'clock at night I gotta
I missed my meal well I'll get I'll give
it a chance I'll give it a try I know I
definitely need to [ __ ] stress less
and that's always like one of my goals I
haven't been drinking this year though
the day after the Rose Bowl is the last
time I I had one gulp of wine after I
made this really rich dinner in my
stomach I needed to settle it so I my
wife was drinking some wine I just took
a gulp of that and then the last three
nights in a row
I'm getting rid of these Rose Bowl beers
I just drink like one light beer I just
have one and then I'm done and it just
kind of makes me sleepy but I'm just
trying to free up some room in the
fridge because every year at the end of
the Rose Bowl I get stuck with all the
extra beers and like [ __ ] 15 cans of
half you
mustard I get all the condiments and a
broken cooler
all right trash in the ocean hey Bill I
know you talk about this all the time on
your podcast but believe it or not there
are people who do not believe our trash
being dumped in the ocean is a problem
well there's always going to be those
people there's also people don't thought
the [ __ ] world was flat well I guess
I would have thought the world is flat
if I lived back then people didn't think
that we were we running an effect on the
climate you know all the [ __ ] trees
that we've cut down that alone you know
what I mean it's all right anyways he
says there was another scientific study
done if you believe in that kind of
thing that states plastics will outweigh
fish in the ocean by 2050 yeah I saw
that I don't think that that's going to
happen because I have a feeling that
Mother Nature has had enough with us and
we'll you know when they keep predicting
by 2090 the population will more than
[ __ ] quintuple I think that you know
we're already long past the tipping
point scientists have said we're past
the point where we can even fix this
[ __ ] thing so I this is like when you
can't do your homework at some point you
like mom and she comes down and helps
you out I think mother nature is gonna
do that and she's an old school mom and
she's gonna slap the [ __ ] out of us but
you don't need to listen to me say this
just listen to George Carlin he'll tell
you all about it
alright he said I guess these [ __ ]
assume they'll be dead by then and don't
give a [ __ ]
longtime listener here just saw you in
Indy back in October I can assure you we
aren't all ignorant KKK [ __ ] or Jim
Irsay fancy and I you know I just say
that just to [ __ ] with you Jesus Christ
I grew up outside of Boston half the
people in the Klan would go there and be
like all right hey take it easy you know
easy
I understand but easy all right thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself and then they sent
me the unbelievably depressing link
which I don't I don't even go to him
anymore I don't even go to him anymore
because all they do is depress me
all right average amount of waste
reduced by humans Jesus Christ would
just staring into this hey Bill I'm from
Colombia and loved your podcasts and you
stand-up comedy hey that's [ __ ] great
oh you're from Colombia I thought you
were down there listening but whatever
you from there right you live there at
some point you still listen to the
podcast it's still cool he goes the or
she goes I don't know who the [ __ ] wrote
this he goes the other day I was
wondering how much poop is produced by
humans on a daily basis and I did a
little research on the internet and some
calculations which I would like to share
with you and your audience okay
according to the World Factbook the
world population consists of seven
billion one hundred seventy four
thousand six hundred eleven wait a
minute oh it's seven billion 174 million
six hundred eleven thousand five hundred
eighty four people and the average human
being weighs around sixty two kilograms
oh you [ __ ] I know I want to
know what that isn't pounds I got it I
got to switch that over I want to see
where the [ __ ] I'm at wait what did you
just say 62 what do you guys think the
average person who I even say the
average person weighs about a hundred a
lot of starving people
I'll go 162 pounds what do you what do
you say here all right 62 and it'll be
yes all right that's equal to 136 pounds
holy [ __ ] god damn it there's a lot of
small or starving people in the world
all right now the average that means I
am right now I'm like 40 pounds over the
average and the average human being
right now the daily average for stool
rows is one ounce for 12 pounds of body
weight which means the average person
poops 11.3 nine ounces therefore each
day the planet receives two million two
hundred ninety five thousand eight
seventy-six metric tons of [ __ ] but
since the average stool is 75% water
dude this is gross it would be safe to
say that humans produce 1 million seven
or 20 1907 metric tons of poop every day
Jesus Christ you're really taking all
the fun out of this podcast to put this
in perspective I think you put it into
perspective but he's gonna keep going
the Empire State Building weighs 350,000
tons so human beings puke the equivalent
of 5 giant turds the size of the Empire
State Building if we add farts to the
equation the average person farts 17
times a day that's it
try eating a salad [ __ ] w numbers you
break Dan Marino's record times 17 times
a day producing a litter a liter of fart
in total a litter Li tter that's a
litter of fart in total which gives a
new meaning to a breathing fresh air I
have included the links where I got the
information at the end of this email and
when you think about it on top of eating
our own rollerblades we're eating our
own [ __ ] by the way everything you read
or hear about Columbia is true that go
have a meaningful experience with
yourself I mean go that means go [ __ ]
yourself ah this guy's a clever son of a
[ __ ] um Jesus Christ well you know what
hey how about I end the podcast with
what I promised to do last week which is
I was going to start reading segments
from the Bible now granted I don't own a
Bible all right let's start with John
3:16 because I'm a sports fan John 3:16
he said it unto you with all right John
3:16 for God so loved the world that He
gave His only is one and only
son that whoever believes in Him shall
not perish perish but have eternal life
well that's straightforward he let his
kid die so as long as you believe that
that happened you will not die you will
have eternal life you will live forever
think about that forever you know you
ever been at the DMV just imagine that
except it never ends right what the [ __ ]
would you do forever there's no way that
that's [ __ ] true you know movies
don't go on forever planets don't go on
forever or livable planets don't go on
forever I'll [ __ ] this is why I don't
read the Bible and I saw I don't [ __ ]
get it all right let's let's let's just
look up Bible passages be ible you'd be
funny if this actually got me back to
going to church
I still love going to church you know
what I mean I still like going you know
keep in mind dad Jesus Christ has died
for us and is risen from the dead all
right
encouraging Bible verses hope Bible
verses Bible verses bite friendships
Bible verses let's give hope encouraging
well where the [ __ ] is it I just wanted
to open it like the phone book the Bible
I'm gonna look up the Bible please read
the Bible
WWF Reeb I belong your phone I don't
want it I want it on my [ __ ] screen
don't wanna amber know what cheeseburger
official Kim James Bible commit thy way
unto the Lord Trust also in him and he
shall bring it to pass
bring what commit thy way unto the Lord
all right so walk in the general
direction of the Lord Trust also in him
well if I'm walking towards him our need
isn't that trusting him
I think I'm creeping up on him a man
just making sure everything's cool I'm
walking your way but you know just wave
your white flag don't open a trap door
when I get there dude and he shall bring
it to pass
Genisys I remember reading this it like
makes sense for like three [ __ ]
sentences and then you just like what in
the beginning God created the heaven and
the earth and the earth was without form
and void and darkness was upon the face
of the deep period the deep what and the
Spirit of God moved upon that's like
when they go you know they got to eat up
some clock darkness was upon the face of
the deep and the Spirit of God moved
upon the face of the waters I thought
there wasn't any thought there wasn't
any war there wasn't anything how was
there water for his face to be on and
God said let there be light and there
was light
let there be sound that was sound
response God God said let there be light
and there was light well what was he
doing before that he was just sitting in
the darkness all by himself
just one day he's laying there guy I'm
gonna make some [ __ ] and God saw the
light that it was good and God divided
the light from the darkness God called
the light day it's like Cam Newton
everything's about the same guy I'll
tell you right now nobody's having more
fun than God making earth he's like a
kid in a candy store that doesn't exist
and kids don't exist because he hasn't
made it yet
ah [ __ ] this Genesis let's look up job
let's see what old job had to say where
the [ __ ] is he well let's read Titus
that's the name of a comic I know how
about that alright Paul a servant of God
and an apostle of Jesus Christ according
to the faith of God's elect and the
acknowledging of the truth which is
after godliness
I feel like somebody's trying to sell me
a car that was all one sentence in hope
of eternal life which God that cannot
lie promised before the world began dude
this is like like God called everything
you know before you even born and all
but half and do times manifested his
words you know I thought this would be a
funny bit this is just [ __ ] annoying
but half and dude times manifested his
word through preaching which is
committed unto me according to the
commandment of God our Savior it's just
it just goes in circles to Titus my own
son after the common faith he had
another kid yet Jesus then he had Titus
grace mercy and peace who were they was
grace grace did was she another virgin
how many times is he gonna use this
virgin thing he banged him right he had
Jesus with Mary and then grace was his
[ __ ] side piece and he had Titus all
right for this cause left IV and Crete
that thou should have set in order the
things that are wanting and orders
elders in every city as I appointed thee
if any be blameless the husband of one
wife having faithful children not
accused of riot or unruly it's not a
sentient or maybe it was back then you
know what if I get judged Sunday you
know and and God's standing there and
being like I just affected I you know I
tried to get through I tried to get
through the book I don't know what to
tell you as far as I can see it's a
bunch of fragments all right they're not
complete thoughts you know you can't
write just because you put a period at
the end of it doesn't make it a sentence
right all right that's the podcast for
this week once again congratulations to
the Broncos congratulations still the
lady you've got a job I'm gonna end this
positive congratulations to the lady you
got the job there at the Buffalo Bills
I'm sure you're gonna do a great job I'm
just a grumpy old [ __ ] man whose team
lost all right congratulations to the
Panthers I look forward to seeing Cam
Newton you know play against Peyton man
it's gonna be great I love that he
called him the sheriff I thought that
was cool you know the best of the old
versus the best of the new so I'm an old
[ __ ] so I'm gonna have to root I got a
group for the Denver Broncos the AFC and
Peyton Manning even though I love the
Panthers and I love the way they [ __ ]
play in that defense is to [ __ ] and I
don't know I just hope it's a good game
I hope the Panthers if they're gonna win
or the Broncos I just don't want anybody
beating the [ __ ] out of anybody right
but I will tell you as always I will be
watching it by myself
okay I'm not going to I might go to a
Super Bowl party because my team's on it
but I don't think so I want to see
Peyton's last game and I hope he goes
out like Elway and I'm gonna do what I
always do all right I'm gonna tape the
game you let it go for a good 90 minutes
as I mentioned you shut your phone off
you get the grill going you crack a
couple of beers you know you make
yourself a burger or two you invite a
couple of friends over then you go all
right let's sit down and watch it and
you blow through all the [ __ ]
beginning and the brave right boom
kickoff and there we go
blow through all the [ __ ] commercials
fast-forward through Beyonce
lip-synching during halftime you'll get
caught up halfway through the third
[ __ ] quarter and and if there were
any cool commercials that you missed you
have them recorded but someone's gonna
put them up online anyways you're not
gonna miss a [ __ ] thing and he's
gonna watch the Superbowl and about I
don't know you can watch it about to two
hours in 20 minutes to our two and a
half hours it's [ __ ] tremendous all
right god bless you guys yet go [ __ ]
yourselves then I'll check on you on
Thursday all right